uno no aspira a lo que no conoce
tenemos la idea de que los grandes
pensadores las grandes mentes las
personas más brillantes del mundo de
méjico de baja california de mexicalli
nacieron con superpoderes
en cambio nosotros estamos limitados a
nuestro contexto en nuestro entorno a
nuestro ambiente a nuestro ecosistema
uno no aspira a lo que no conoce
vamos a presentar el ejemplo un ejemplo
hipotético de cuatro niños cuatro niñas
aquí de mexicalli la primera tenemos a
juana juanita estudia en calexico
juanita vive con su papá vive con su
mamá su mayor preocupación es llegar de
la escuela y ponerse a ver vídeos en
youtube tenemos por otro lado a mario
mario estudia a quién mexicalli en una
escuela particular mario por las tardes
trabaja con sus papás en la panadería a
mario le han inculcado el valor el
sentido del dinero a marian en plan
inculcado el trabajo y mario quiere ser
de grande como sus papás
tenemos el caso de lupita lupita
estudiar a una escuela pública aquí en
mexicali
lupita se quiere desarrollar pero tiene
un contexto familiar un poco adverso
lupita quiere acaba el bachillerato y
espera no quedar embarazada y espera en
algún momento ponerse a estudiar una
carrera técnica
desde el contexto que viven nuestros
niños y jóvenes no solo en méxico sino
del mundo y que nos une a todos ellos
que tiene en común estos cuatro niños
una sola cosa todos son mexicanos y
todos estos niños y estos jóvenes
nacieron ya sea con la adversidad o con
el privilegio de que el destino o el
azar los puso en el lugar donde están
por lo tanto hay que contar la historia
de ramón
sabían ustedes que cuando salgamos aquí
del auditorio tres niños habrán sido
asesinados en nuestro país tres niños
habrán muerto por causas no naturales
sabían ustedes que el día de mañana 50%
de nuestros niños vivirán en alguna
condición de pobreza
y que en agosto cuando empecemos el
siguiente ciclo escolar 2.4 millones de
niños de educación básica no van a poder
estar estudiando 2.5 millones de
nuestros niños se van a encontrar
laborando no estudiando
mientras tanto un tercio de nuestros
niños viven alguna situación de
inseguridad alimentaria de quien baja
california y en méxico uno de cada seis
de nuestros jóvenes entre 15 y 19 años
no estudia ni trabaja
poniendo en un contexto más local son
ustedes que el 40 por ciento de los
jóvenes aquí en baja california al
momento de graduarse de secundaria van a
abandonar la escuela
y los datos más intrigantes que está
pasando con la desigualdad de género
sólo 1 de cada 4 científicos en nuestro
país es mujer cuantas ingenieras si
tienen ustedes que habrán
sólo 2 de cada 10 ingenieros en nuestro
país son mujer poniendo estos datos como
contexto les vengo a platicar la
historia de cómo un grupo de jóvenes no
sólo aquí en mexicali sino por toda
latinoamérica
estamos trabajando para inspirar a que
nuestros niños aspiren a una mejor
calidad de vida
partiendo de la premisa de que es
inspirar que se imaginan ustedes que
significa inspirar para mí inspirar
significó el tener cuatro años estar
sentado en la oficina de mi papá mi
abuelo el haber sentido que algún día
iba a llenar esa silla ese fue un primer
momento clave de mi vida en el que dije
para mí es inspiración que me despertó
una semilla que tuve esa premisa de
querer ser
pero cuántos nos quedamos en el camino
de la inspiración y no llegamos a la
aspiración cuando nos quedamos en el
camino de me gustaría yo quisiera
algún día y no pasamos a aspirar
les voy a poner este vídeo
play
este la historia de un joven de un niño
de 7 años que de navidad pidió una
empresa un niño de 7 años
quería dedicarse a las computadoras y
dino de 7 años en algún momento de su
vida pudo conocer lo que era una
impresora y dijo yo me quiero dedicar a
las computadoras yo me quiero dedicar a
esto toda mi vida
actualmente este joven estudió
ingeniería mecatrónica no aprendió a
programar muy bien se tuvo que cambiar
de carrera de ingeniería mecánica
mecatrónica porque le dio la vuelta a
los programas de diseño pero pues está
trabajando bajo una aspiración que tuvo
yo quiero dedicarme que las computadoras
a que la tecnología llegue al alcance de
todos nuestros niños y puede que los 7
años no supiéramos esa idea a los 7 años
estamos pensando sin jugar estamos
pensando en bailar estamos pensando en
pintar
pero como esas pequeñas sumas de
acciones de experiencias nos llevan a
hacer lo que somos
demostrar
evra
bien
pasó dos años
y llega un momento crucial en la vida de
todos nosotros a mí me pasó una
secundaria donde la aspiración cae donde
la aspiración se muere
qué está pasando con qué 40% de nuestros
jóvenes aquí en baja california el
aumento de grasa la secundaria abandona
la escuela
por fortuna yo no fui uno de esos casos
pero en mi trayecto brincando al
bachillerato no tenga inspiración por
más que mis papás me decían por más que
mis amigos me decían por más que mi
familia me decía no había una motivación
en mi vida
alguno de ustedes recordarán esta
película esta pelicula agradece a kevin
spacey que se llama anyone blackjack me
tocó verla en 2008 cuando salió yo tenía
14 años y algo muy clave de esa película
me marcó conocí lo que era el mighty
pude ver yo en la secundaria el niño que
la primaria tenía unos mejores promedios
al momento mental la secundaria me di
cuenta y en la preparatoria fue cuando
me di cuenta de lo que estaba pasando
bajo promedio por miedo que me dijeran
nerd bajo promedio por media que me
catalogaban como los que no son cool
baje promedio por miedo a ser
estigmatizado como un niño antisocial
como un niño de que las personas que
aspiran las personas que tienen sueños
son rechazadas porque vas a estar
hablando en secundaria de robots ponte a
pensar en hacer desastre ponte a pensar
en grafitear ponte a pensar te pinte
arte la escuela para mí kevin spacey y
mis papás fueron ese motor en la
preparatoria que me encaminaron a
conocer lo que era la universidad de
maite
voy terminando la preparatoria empiezo a
aplicar a universidades y yo tengo la
menta yo quiero llegarle mighty está en
mis sueños están y motivación aplico a
la escuela tengo la primera entrevista
teléfonica paso a la entrevista tengo la
oportunidad de ir a presentarme con un
ex alumno y tener mi entrevista personal
pasó esta entrevista al poco de los
meses me llega la carta felicidades
fuiste un muy buen prospecto pero no
fuiste admitido
qué pasa por nuestro mundo nos
hubiéramos caído nos hubiéramos tumbado
pero la misma motivación y aspiración
que me fueron sembrando esa misma bolita
de nieve que estoy pasando en mi vida me
llevo a esto a poder aplicar y decir yo
quiero explorar a mejores universidades
del mundo
vamos a aplicar stanford vamos a quedar
admitidos en su programa de
certificación de negocios
internacionales un joven de 19 años
entre puro grandote de maestría en un
programa de verano durante los veranos
una certificación en negocios
internacionales y fue ese momento en el
que me di cuenta en el que después de
muchos años se prendió el poquito llegó
el momento ajá llegó este momento que te
dices yo quiero dedicar el resto de mi
vida a inspirar y que jóvenes talento
que jóvenes sin importar el contexto la
edad la religión la posición económica
deban y tengan que tener acceso a
innovación
no soy yo
vamos a poner dos ejemplos
esta persona de origen británico indio
ramón luján que tendrá de similar con
tres niños de mexicalli en los más altas
este joven que falleció hace algunas
décadas fue catalogado como uno de los
mejores matemáticos autodidactas
este joven no tuvo la oportunidad de
existir a una escuela prestigiosa no
tuvo la oportunidad de estar en contexto
con maestros con docentes con
catedráticos este joven a los 11 años
encontró arrumbado en su casa un libro
de cálculo y con su poco conocimiento de
aritmética de geometría de matemáticas
empezó a resolver los ejercicios al
momento de estar resolviendo encontró
que su pasión eran los números
casualidad destino como podemos
catalogarlo
hace dos años tuvimos la oportunidad de
una intervención en la comunidad de
lomas altas que se encuentra al sur
oeste de nuestra ciudad fue en verano
2017 dos semanas antes de empezar esa
intervención con estos niños pasó una
situación muy trágica en su vida como
podrán haber visto las noticias de hace
dos años se quemaron dos casas en la
colonia por medio de actos de vandalismo
y fallecieron cuatro niños amigos de
juan de pedro y luis por poner los
nombres por cuestiones de
confidencialidad
estos niños sí por si el contexto
adverso donde había ausentismo de alguna
figura paterna o materna había
alcoholismo había violencia había una
serie de contextos adversos en su vida
decidió dar el intento y decir vamos a
ver qué podemos hacer con la robótica
vamos a darle una oportunidad después de
un mes de intervención uno de los niños
nos comentaba su mamá que tiene que
caminar a veces hasta unas dos horas
para llegar a la escuela de verano para
poder tener el taller los niños
concluyeron que por medio de la
tecnología podían empezar a resolver
problemáticas reales de su comunidad no
sólo era programar por armar armar por
armar era que por medio de estos robots
de esta tecnología de esta serie de
inventos podían hacer un impacto real en
su comunidad
qué tiene en común estas dos personas a
miles de kilómetros a decenas de años de
distancia
de origen no equivale a destino
es por eso que pasamos de una necesidad
de estar trabajando con niños con
jóvenes inspirando los a verlo como una
obligación es nuestra obligación a cada
uno de ustedes el ser un motor de
inspiración cuántos de ustedes cuántos
de nosotros hemos sido juez hemos sido
parte en decir para que lo intentas para
que estudias ingeniería sin puros
hombres ahí mejor dedícate a la cocina
palabras que hemos escuchado de parte de
algunos padres de familia científica
estos son para los niños chinos
vamos a tecnología propia para que están
los coreanos no tenemos que hacer nada
aquí
cuanto nosotros hemos sido jueces y
hemos sido parte en estos ejemplos
y la inspiración no es solo que te caiga
el 20 y decir ahora ser y que quiero
quiero ser astronauta ahora amo dedicar
a esto a jada es simplemente una fórmula
matemática que es la suma de los
recuerdos anécdotas experiencias y
aprendizajes cómo hacemos para
incrementar ese valor cómo hacemos para
que el recuerdo que pase de una
experiencia de violencia pasa a ser un
recuerdo de alegría como hacemos del
aprendizaje que vemos el teorema de
pitágoras en secundaria lo podamos ver
aplicado a la robótica cómo hacemos que
esas anécdotas que los maestros nos
contaban en algún momento de nuestra
vida digamos con que para eso sirvió
filosofía con que para esto servía
literatura con qué metodología y la
investigación si tenía algo que ver en
nuestra vida
poniéndolos y siguiendo con ejemplos de
datos
si dividimos al país a nuestra población
en cinco segmentos siendo uno el más
pobre siendo 5 el más rico se imaginan
que el segmento más pobre la mitad se va
a quedar igual y sólo el 2% va a poder
tener esa movilidad social y del 20% de
la población más rica de nuestro país el
75 por ciento seguirá igual y sólo el 1%
vendrá y se sentarán con el 20% más
pobre
que estamos haciendo para que esta
movilidad social incremente
este niño que parece que está rapeando
en realidad le está contando a sus
amigos
que por medio de una impresora 3d el
niño podía fabricar prótesis para formar
la que había perdido la pierna hace
algunos meses dale una pistola a un niño
será bandolero dale una pelota a un niño
querrás el futbolista ponle una serie de
experiencias enfrente y quiera cambiar
el mundo
fuimos la oportunidad en agosto del año
pasado de ir a visitar china en conjunto
con dos jóvenes de preparatoria y su
mentor
todo salió mal hasta el día de la
competencia poniéndolo como contexto
estos dos jóvenes que los dos compartían
que no tenían figura paterna que no
querían que no querían terminar el
bachillerato que se querían poner a
trabajar seis meses antes de haber
llegado a china ganaron segundo lugar en
morelia en un concurso latinoamericano
que tuvo que haber pasado para ese
brinco seis meses antes que no conocían
nada de robótica seis meses antes que no
conocían nada de fabricación llegó su
mentor y les dijo yo sé que ustedes
no los ven a nosotros como un ejemplo yo
sé que ustedes nos ven como una
autoridad como el maestro como el
abusivo como esta figura que tengo que
revelar me pero yo creo en ustedes qué
les parece si le damos la oportunidad
a resolver estos retos hay que dar esa
oportunidad puede que ustedes no
conozcan nada de programación puede que
ustedes estén años-luz de las escuelas
en china en japón y korea pero qué le
parece si les damos esta oportunidad nos
lamentamos perfecto
fuimos representando a méxico en un
campeonato mundial de robótica no
obtuvimos los mejores lugares pero nos
llevamos un aprendizaje clave que estos
jóvenes actualmente están siendo
multiplicadores y están siendo
inspiradores no secaron o más a la
competencia al momento de terminar los
jóvenes por decisión propia con otras
escuelas fueron a otros lugares a
inspirar a más jóvenes origen no
equivale a destino será complicado sí
este es uno de mis casos favoritos que
vemos en pantalla cuatro jóvenes tres
son de la casa-hogar caoba uno de ellos
es de la escuela feliz de jesús a simple
vista no podemos diferenciar quién
pertenece a cada escuela en uno de
nuestros talleres en una de las
intervenciones empezamos a trabajar con
niños de diferentes comunidades
empezamos a hacer una integración y nos
encontramos con este claro ejemplo si
ponemos a niños de diferentes contextos
si ponemos a niños que han pasado por
diferentes situaciones en un mismo
camino lograremos maravillas estos tres
niños esos cuatro niños que puede que no
compartían ni los mismos gustos de
televisión puede que unos tienen tenido
internet otros no compartían el mismo
objetivo queremos ser mejores y queremos
ser superarnos les faltó nomás un poco
de inspiración un poco la aspiración de
parte de nuestro equipo para que
obtuvieran el primer lugar en uno de los
concursos de ciencias más importantes de
nuestro estado
no equivale a destino
y como estamos preparando a los
trabajadores del futuro 14% de los
trabajos en méxico tienen un alto índice
y un alto riesgo de desaparición en
realidad estamos preparando a los niños
ya los jóvenes para actividades del
futuro en realidad ahora estamos
inspirando para que sigan un mejor
camino y una mejor vida
esto queda en sus manos el futuro del
trabajo es incierto nosotros tenemos la
obligación de diseñarlo
es por eso que al momento que nos
preguntan si el camino ha sido difícil
claro que ha sido difícil si nos
encontramos en un lugar importante si
nos encontramos en la frontera
encontramos un lugar muy muy importante
si hay motivación claro que encontramos
motivación en lo más alto en valle y
repuebla la zona dorada en la robledo en
l'air algo en todas las colores
encontramos motivación falta no más
inspirar y hacer que estos niños aspiran
y sobre todo si les sembramos la
siguiente frase a los niños que ha sido
el motor los últimos años de lo que
estamos haciendo
si hubiéramos sabido que esto era
imposible
no lo hubiéramos intentado y como
nosotros no sabíamos que esto era
imposible nosotros lo hicimos muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]